it's a 1952 Chrysler Town and Country
station wagon basically inspired me to
do the build you know but the idea well
let's restore the hell out of it let's
not do anything to the outside of the
car we're alternative transportation
company the idea is to take all the
perversions and wonderment of modern
technology and transportation design but
integrate that with more storied
aesthetic back from when automobiles
were more of a design driven product
than what the big companies are doing
today automobiles and just design at
large we're always my main passion
having come from classic car restoration
slowly I started listening to people say
well you know I want something that
behaves like a new car that is a lot
more character
we have projects active currently from
Aston Martin's to Lincoln Zephyrs and
everything in between
we've grown every year for the last 18
years but I think a big problem for us
it is tremendously complicated and
time-consuming to do what we do we have
such a wildly diverse customer base
probably the the one consistent is it's
it's all guys it helps them kind of shed
work and city life and all that like on
is like a unique opportunity to be in
something that's bespoke it's distinct
its unique but it's not hi look at me
aren't I special or better